You can wish Santa.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in real
Abu
[Silence]
Abu OM
is one of the probably lesserk known
companions of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam to the general masses.
However, Abu alahi is known as albei
is one of the great companions and
scholars of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's disciples.
He narrates to us that the messenger of
Allah sallall.aii
said,
he says, "The virtue that a scholar
holds over a
aid
or someone who is very
dutiful.
Arabid is someone who
has kind of
devoted himself and devoted the mass
bulk of his or her time to the worship
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. So he's
referred to as what? as aid
is someone who is very devout, very
dutiful in his worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala from amongst the
general population of the Muslim. He
says the virtue that a scholar holds
over aid
is the virtue that I hold over the
least amongst you.
He's speaking about himself.
He's saying that the virtue that the
scholar holds over thee dutiful
dutiful in the worship of Allah devout
but is not a person of knowledge as a
layman a lay Muslim but he is or she is
someone who has devoted the majority of
his or her life to the worship of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
constantly in fasting or remembrance of
Allah or or salah or zaka or jihad.
This is
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam says to
the companions the virtue that a scholar
holds over the most dutiful
is the virtue that I hold over the
least amongst you. the most obscure
unknown companion who maybe just
interacted with the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam once in his life because again
what is a companion? A companion is
anyone who saw the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam as a believer and died upon
Islam. That's what a companion is. So
the bare minimum is that a person be
Muslim and see the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam even if he doesn't speak to
him. This is now a companion as long as
he dies upon that belief.
So he's saying the virtue that a scholar
holds over is the virtue that I
hold over the least amongst you.
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. And in
another wording of this same narration
in
the prophet Sam
says
he said the virtue that a scholar holds
over aid
is the virtue that the moon holds
over the rest of all the stars in the
sky.
meaning how much more pronounced is the
moon? How much more
necessary, how much more dire is the
moon to our existence and our experience
here on this earth.
So much more than our need for the rest
of the stars. We need all of these
celestial bodies. We need it all.
They're there for a reason.
But the moon cannot be done without.
If one of the stars in the sky went out
or 10 or 20 or 100 or 200,
maybe perhaps certain people wouldn't
notice. The majority of humanity may not
notice. However, if the if the moon
didn't rise tomorrow, if it disappeared,
what would happen to humanity?
Everything would change. Even the
deepest part of the ocean would change.
and
the most obscure part of the earth would
change because of the absence of the
moon.
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
says the virtue that a scholar holds
over the rest of the devout
is the virtue that the moon holds
over the rest of the stars in the sky.
The virtue that a scholar holds over the
generally devout is the virtue that
I hold over the least amongst you. He
then says
[Silence]
He then follows this up with saying,
"Indeed, Allah
and his angels and the inhabitants of
the heavens and the earth, even an ant
in its hole,
and a fish in the sea, all are making a
salah upon those who teach the people
good."
making a salah upon them. A salah. What
is this from the people?
[Silence]
What is in this context? Salah from the
rest from humanity is a dua. But it's
not just any dua. It's not just any
supplication.
A salah. When I say for instance or you
say Allah,
oh Allah, may your salah be upon
whoever the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
It is a dua that Allah raise that
person's esteem.
[Silence]
A
is that a person is saying Allah. It
means oh Allah
raise the mention
and the esteem of this person and make
mention of him in the highest of
company in the heavens. you know those
who are closest to Allah, the ones who
carry his throne and Gibl and Mika and
the angels that are essentially more
or less as his courtiers
those who are closest to Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
is that you are making dua that Allah
make mention of that person in that
gathering to those who are closest to
Allah. So when you sayham,
you are essentially saying, "Oh Allah, I
ask that you raise the esteem and
mention of Muhammad in the highest of
levels and in the highest of settings.
That is what a salah is." So the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam. Here he
tells us that Allah and his angels
and the inhabitants of the heavens and
the earth and even the ant in its hole
and the fish in its sea all make a salah
upon those individuals who teach the
people good. Teach the people good
meaning the scholars. That's how it ties
in to the first part of the narration.
And what is meant by knowledge? What is
meant by scholar? A scholar is someone
who has learned immensely and is deeply
rooted in knowledge of the Quran,
the Sunnah, and the companions.
That's what knowledge is.
[Silence]
says that knowledge is Allah said, his
messenger said, the companion said,
and he says that
ignorant Ignance is a deadly disease.
It is fatal. Ignorance 100% fatal.
I know sometimes we get confused
because we have told ourselves certain
excuses.
Well, if I don't know any better than my
heart is in the right place and you know
I just didn't know but my heart is in
the right place, I'll be okay because
Allah knows what's in my heart. If your
heart was in the right place, you would
learn what Allah wants from you.
If you haven't learned what Allah wants
from you, your heart is not in the right
place. No matter if you don't double
park or take your garbage out every
Tuesday and Thursday or whatever else
you figure is makes you a good person, a
good person is only the one who is good
in the scales of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
And the whole concept of, well, at least
I'm not as bad as that guy over there.
Trust me, on the day of judgment, that
guy over there will not factor in to
your judgment in front of Allah in any
way.
And that's why as human beings, one of
the reasons psychologically we to
hear about, you know, true crime and
terrible murderers and serial killers
and it makes us feel well, I'm not
so bad. Look, I didn't kill a bunch of
people and bury them in my basement. I
didn't dress up a clown and kidnap
children. I'm not that bad.
And so
ignorance when a person says a Muslim in
today's society, is there any one person
amongst us here who is illiterate? does
not know how to read or write.
A person amongst us who does not have
access to the Quran and Sunnah. A person
amongst us who does not have access to
the scholars of Islam or at least one
scholar. The problem is is that if that
is your situation,
you will be held accountable for not
learning. You will who what gives you
the right to attempt to worship Allah
without knowing how Allah wants to be
worshiped? What gives you that right?
What gives you that right? What gives me
that right?
When you get a job, do you just march
in, put your feet up on the desk, and do
whatever you and say, "Hey, hey,
hey, hey, my heart's in the right place.
Relax." Is that what you say?
Imagine someone goes barreling down the
road 100 miles an hour. police officer
stops him, says, "You You're driving
recklessly. How could you speed that
fast?" And your answer is, "Oh, I didn't
know speeding was illegal."
Would that be a good answer? Tell me. I
Speeding is illegal. I didn't know. See,
I looked at the car. It goes up to 220
mph. I assumed that that's as fast as I
could go.
How old are you? Where have you been
born? How long have you lived in this
country? You never heard you got a
driver's license. You never heard
that speeding is illegal.
Does that work with the IRS? Do we p
prepare ourselves with the IRS in the
same manner? In the same way that we
prepare ourselves for Allah.
Well, my heart's in the right place.
What happens if I don't pay my taxes?
Well, the IRS will show up and I will
tell them emphatically in no uncertain
terms, I'm not an accountant.
I don't know.
But
I did not intend to break the law. My
heart was in the right place.
Has any of us prepared for that? Not one
of us. We would assume that person is
either disingenuous or
something's wrong upstairs. Maybe the
elevator isn't going all the way to the
penthouse kind of thing. That is not
an argument in any reasonable setting.
So why has that become our argument in
front of Allah?
Well, I didn't know or I'm not a scholar
is the exact same answer as giving I'm
not an accountant to the IRS. Same
thing.
You're not an accountant. Why didn't you
take your taxes to an accountant? Why
didn't you ask? You didn't care. That's
the reason
or you're being disingenuous.
And so in this age, the age of
information, and I will not say the
age of knowledge, this is the age of
ignorance, people have never had more
access to to information and have never
been more ignorant at the same time.
to the to the point that every single
field of human knowledge and
epistemology has all dipped. All of
them. All of them.
We have
more information than we know what to do
with and we have more ignorance rampant
amongst us than we have ever seen
perhaps in the history of humanity in a
holistic way.
So knowledge
it is your your your honor when you
learn what Allah said and the prophet
said this is why
says ignorance is a deadly disease 100%
fatality rate ignorance
he says and the the cure to ignorance
is a verse from the Quran or a statement
of our prophet sallall.aii wasallam and
the prescription is to be taken from
from a scholar. He is the prescriber to
those those medicines. You don't just
open the Quran and jump in. You go to a
scholar. You say, "This is the issue
that I'm having."
That's what he's for. Just when you
go to the doctor, you say, "This itches
or this hurts or this is uncomfortable."
He gives you the antidote. You don't
just go into the pharmacy and start
picking stuff up off the shelves a
bull in a china cabinet and saying,
"Maybe this will work. Maybe I'll try
some of this. Maybe I'll try some of
this. These taste good. Ooh, that tastes
nasty. I don't want that." You're going
to kill yourself. And that is exactly
what happens when you just jump in to
the vastness of the Quran and Sunnah is
very vast. You have to have a doctor
prescribe to you exactly what ails you.
He will give you the prescription. You
have to take the medicine and you will
by Allah's will be cured.
Allah subhu
[Silence]
alhamdulillah.
He's going to Where's he going?
California.
[Arabic recitation]